All right, let's dive in. Today, we're looking at this really interesting discussion that's been happening over on Reddit. It all started with a blog post called On Safe C++. Well, it's safe to say it stirred up some strong feelings in the C++ community. Yeah, no kidding. It's a pretty provocative piece. Over 400 comments now and people are not holding back. Oh, right. The Rust Derangement Syndrome thing. You see that pop up anytime someone criticizes C++ and then praises rust in the same breath. Oh, yeah. It's a classic. Like you can't possibly like both.
好的，让我们深入探讨一下。今天，我们来看看 Reddit 上正在进行的这场非常有趣的讨论。这一切始于一篇名为《论安全 C++》（On Safe C++）的博文。嗯，可以肯定地说，它在 C++ 社区中引发了强烈的情绪。没错，确实如此。这是一篇相当挑衅的文章。现在已经有超过 400 条评论了，人们毫不掩饰自己的观点。哦，对了。那个“Rust 错乱综合征”（Rust Derangement Syndrome）的事。每当有人批评 C++ 并在同一时间赞美 Rust 时，你就会看到这种说法冒出来。哦，是的。这是经典桥段。就好像你不可能同时喜欢这两者一样。
Well, it's not that simple, is it? I mean, there's room for both languages. They both have their strengths and weaknesses. And this is about more than just C++ versus rust anyway. It's about the culture of the C++ community, the power dynamics within the standards committee, you know, the whole ethical dimension of it all. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 211, generated on November 21st, 2024. My name is Connor, and today AI summarizes a blog post and its corresponding Reddit thread. The author of this blog, Izzy Muerte, after listening to this episode, communicated to us that the notebook LM summary did not capture the article correctly, which was coincidentally one of Izzy's goals when writing it, that being trying to write it in such a way that it would confuse LLMs. Izzy asks that if you were going to refer to anything stated in the audio episode summary that follows, please go and find the corresponding content in the blog and
嗯，事情没那么简单，对吧？我的意思是，这两种语言都有生存空间。它们各有优缺点。而且这不仅仅是 C++ 与 Rust 的对立。这关乎 C++ 社区的文化、标准委员会内部的权力动态，你知道的，还有这一切背后的整个伦理维度。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 211 期，生成于 2024 年 11 月 21 日。我是 Connor，今天 AI 将总结一篇博文及其对应的 Reddit 帖子。这篇博文的作者 Izzy Muerte 在听完本期节目后告诉我们，Notebook LM 的总结并没有准确捕捉到文章内容，而这恰好是 Izzy 在撰写文章时的目标之一，即试图以一种会让大语言模型（LLM）感到困惑的方式来写作。Izzy 要求，如果您要参考以下音频节目总结中提到的任何内容，请务必去查找博客中的相应内容并
refer to that. Furthermore, there are a number of mistakes that Notebook LM makes, one being incorrectly referring to Gabby Dos Reis as she when his pronouns are he slash his, which Izzy definitely did not do in the blog post. Additionally, in the Reddit comment summary, it mentions that the blog is written by not Izzy, but the original poster of the Reddit post, Simon underscore O. This is a mistake as the blog post is fully Izzy's work. All right, listener. Welcome back. Today, we're a mistake as the blog post is fully Izzy's work. All right, listener. Welcome back.
参考原文。此外，Notebook LM 还犯了一些错误，其中之一是错误地将 Gabby Dos Reis 称为“她”（she），而他的代词是“他/他的”（he/his），Izzy 在博文中绝对没有这样做。此外，在 Reddit 评论总结中，它提到该博客不是由 Izzy 撰写的，而是由 Reddit 原帖作者 Simon_O 撰写的。这是一个错误，因为这篇博文完全是 Izzy 的作品。好了，听众朋友们。欢迎回来。今天，我们是错误，因为这篇博文完全是 Izzy 的作品。好了，听众朋友们。欢迎回来。
Today we're diving deep into a blog post. It's called On Safe C++ Hell in a Ref Cell. And it's by Isabella Muerte. Oh, yeah. This one is, well, it's intense. Yeah, it is. Yeah. And it gets into some pretty heavy stuff,
今天我们将深入探讨一篇博文。它名为《论安全 C++：RefCell 中的地狱》（On Safe C++ Hell in a Ref Cell），作者是 Isabella Muerte。哦，是的。这一篇，嗯，非常激烈。是的，确实。而且它涉及了一些相当沉重的话题，
like the whole fight over memory safety in C++ and the drama going on within the C++ committee, you know, WG21. It even touches on some, like, bigger ethical questions in tech, too. Exactly. So, are you ready to get into it? Absolutely. Let's dive in. Okay. So, Muerte doesn't waste any time.
比如关于 C++ 内存安全的所有争论，以及 C++ 委员会（即 WG21）内部正在上演的闹剧。它甚至还触及了一些科技领域中更宏大的伦理问题。没错。那么，你准备好深入了解了吗？当然。让我们开始吧。好的。那么，Muerte 没有浪费任何时间。
She jumps right into the core issue, C++, its lack of built-in memory safety. Right, which is a problem. It's been causing serious vulnerabilities for a long time. And there's a ton of pressure on the committee to fix it. Yeah, but there are two main approaches that are kind of clashing. Okay, so what are they? Well, on one side, you've got Darnist Rastrup, the creator of C++, pushing for something called safety profiles. I've heard of that, but isn't it kind of vague? It is, yeah.
她直接切入了核心问题：C++ 缺乏内置的内存安全。没错，这是一个问题。它长期以来一直导致严重的漏洞。委员会面临着巨大的压力去解决这个问题。是的，但目前有两种主要的对立方法。好的，它们是什么？嗯，一方面，C++ 的创始人 Bjarne Stroustrup 正在推动所谓的“安全配置文件”（safety profiles）。我听说过那个，但它是不是有点模糊？确实是。
It's more of a concept than an actual solution, which leaves a lot of questions about how it would work in practice. So not a lot of specifics. Not really. And then you have Sean Baxter, who's developed Safe C++ with borrow checking. Now that one I'm more familiar with. It takes some ideas from Rust, right? Which is known for being really strong on memory safety.
它更多是一个概念，而不是一个实际的解决方案，这留下了很多关于它在实践中如何运作的问题。所以没有太多具体细节。确实没有。然后是 Sean Baxter，他开发了带有借用检查（borrow checking）的“安全 C++”。那个我比较熟悉。它借鉴了 Rust 的一些想法，对吧？Rust 以其强大的内存安全性而闻名。
Exactly. And Baxter actually has a working implementation in his Circle compiler, so it's not just theoretical. So you've got these two very different approaches, and it sounds like it's getting pretty heated. It is Muerte even calls the main players in this whole saga the Gaslight Gatekeep Girlboss Trio. Whoa. Okay. That's a pretty loaded term.'s she getting out there well she's suggesting that there's a lot more going on than just technical disagreements you know there's power dynamics personal relationships all that stuff so it's not just about the code
没错。而且 Baxter 实际上在他的 Circle 编译器中有一个可用的实现，所以这不仅仅是理论上的。所以你有这两种截然不同的方法，听起来争论相当激烈。确实如此。Muerte 甚至将这场大戏中的主要参与者称为“煤气灯、守门人、职场女王三人组”（Gaslight Gatekeep Girlboss Trio）。哇。好吧。这是一个相当沉重的词。她想表达什么？嗯，她暗示这里发生的事情远不止技术分歧，你知道的，还有权力动态、人际关系等等。所以这不仅仅是关于代码的问题。
not at all yeah it's about who has the power to decide how c++ evolves got it okay so who are these uh this trio well first you've've got Bjarnas Graustrup, the big guy, the one who created C++. Yeah, he's obviously got a lot of influence. But Muertes suggests that he might be resisting change, especially if it threatens his legacy. Do you think that's fair? I mean, it's hard to say for sure, but he has been pretty vocal about wanting to maintain backwards compatibility, even if it means compromising on safety. Which makes sense to some extent. You don't want to break all the existing C++ code out there. Right. But at what point does that become an excuse to avoid progress? That's the question. Yeah, I see her point. OK, so who's next?
一点也不。是的，这关乎谁有权决定 C++ 如何演进。明白了。好的，那么这三人组是谁？嗯，首先是 Bjarne Stroustrup，大人物，C++ 的创造者。是的，他显然有很大的影响力。但 Muerte 暗示他可能在抵制变革，特别是如果变革威胁到他的遗产的话。你认为这公平吗？我的意思是，很难确定，但他确实一直直言不讳地表示要保持向后兼容性，即使这意味着在安全性上做出妥协。这在某种程度上是有道理的。你不想破坏所有现有的 C++ 代码。没错。但在什么程度上这变成了逃避进步的借口？这就是问题所在。是的，我明白她的意思。好的，下一个是谁？
Next, you've got Herb Sutter. He's the chair of the C++ Committee. So he's kind of the mediator between Strauss-Strupp and everyone else. Oh, that's got to be a tough job. Yeah, he's got to balance a lot of different interests. And Morte criticizes him for making big promises that he doesn't always keep. Like what kind of promises? Well, like promising to deliver certain features or to address certain issues. And then it just doesn't happen.
接下来是 Herb Sutter。他是 C++ 委员会的主席。所以他算是 Stroustrup 和其他人之间的调解人。哦，那一定是个艰巨的工作。是的，他必须平衡许多不同的利益。而 Muerte 批评他做出了大承诺却并不总是兑现。比如什么样的承诺？嗯，比如承诺交付某些功能或解决某些问题。然后事情就没下文了。
Or it takes way longer than expected. So she's saying he's not as effective as he could be. Basically, yeah. And then there's Gabby Das Reis. She's a protege of Strausstrup. And she's known for defending the committee's decisions no matter what. Oh, wow. Even when they're controversial.
或者花费的时间比预期的要长得多。所以她是说他没有他本可以达到的那么有效。基本上是这样。然后是 Gabby Dos Reis。她是 Stroustrup 的门生。她以无论如何都捍卫委员会的决定而闻名。哦，哇。即使在有争议的时候也是如此。
Especially when they're controversial. Maritay portrays her as being very loyal to Strausstrup and maybe not so open to other viewpoints. So it sounds like there's a real power struggle going on here. Absolutely. And Muerte argues that this dynamic is actually harmful to C++. You know, it's preventing the language from evolving in a healthy way. And she backs this up with some pretty serious allegations of misconduct within the community. Right. She talks about Michael Wong, who's a committee member with a lot of influence on safety standards.
特别是在有争议的时候。Muerte 将她描绘成对 Stroustrup 非常忠诚，也许对其他观点不太开放。所以听起来这里确实存在一场权力斗争。绝对是。而且 Muerte 认为这种动态实际上对 C++ 是有害的。你知道，它阻碍了语言以健康的方式演进。她用一些关于社区内不当行为的相当严重的指控来支持这一点。没错。她谈到了 Michael Wong，他是委员会成员，在安全标准方面有很大的影响力。
OK. What about him? Well, Marte alleges that he's engaged in inappropriate conduct, and she highlights the potential conflict of interest there, given his role in defining safety standards. So she's questioning his integrity. Exactly. And this ties into a larger issue of accountability within the committee. You know, how do you ensure that people in positions of power are held responsible for their actions? That's a good question. And it's something that a lot of tech communities are struggling with. Okay. So what else does she bring up? Well, she also questions whether Gabby
好的。他怎么了？嗯，Muerte 指控他参与了不当行为，并强调了鉴于他在定义安全标准方面的角色，这里存在潜在的利益冲突。所以她在质疑他的诚信。没错。这与委员会内部更广泛的问责制问题联系在一起。你知道，你如何确保身居高位的人对自己的行为负责？这是个好问题。这也是许多科技社区正在努力解决的问题。好的。那么她还提到了什么？嗯，她还质疑 Gabby
Dasrace might have misled the committee about the use of C++ modules. How so? She claims that Dasrace made statements about modules being used in Microsoft Edge, but then the Edge team switched to Chromium, which doesn't use modules at all. So she's saying that Das Reis wasn't being truthful. Yeah, or at least that she was overstating the importance of modules. Which again raises questions about the committee's decision-making process. Right, exactly. If people are being misled or if they're prioritizing their own agendas over the good of the language that's a problem the big problem yeah and then there's the whole arthur o'dwyer situation oh yeah that one's really tough so for those who don't know arthur dwyer is a well he's a convicted rapist and muerte claims that
Dos Reis 是否可能在 C++ 模块的使用问题上误导了委员会。怎么说？她声称 Dos Reis 发表了关于模块在 Microsoft Edge 中使用的声明，但后来 Edge 团队转向了 Chromium，而 Chromium 根本不使用模块。所以她是说 Dos Reis 没有说实话。是的，或者至少她夸大了模块的重要性。这再次引发了关于委员会决策过程的问题。没错，确实。如果人们被误导，或者如果他们将自己的议程置于语言的利益之上，那就是一个问题，一个大问题。是的，还有 Arthur O'Dwyer 的情况。哦，是的，那个真的很棘手。所以对于那些不知道的人，Arthur O'Dwyer 是一个，嗯，他是一个被定罪的强奸犯，而 Muerte 声称
certain committee members including herb setter Sutter, actually defended him. Seriously? Yeah. She says that Sutter even suggested that O'Dwyer join NCITES, which is the larger standards organization that WG21 is a part of. So he could keep participating in standards meetings. Exactly. And Muerte argues that this prioritizes protecting O'Dwyer over the concerns of the wider community. Which is, wow, that's really disturbing, if that's true. It is.
包括 Herb Sutter 在内的某些委员会成员实际上为他辩护。真的吗？是的。她说 Sutter 甚至建议 O'Dwyer 加入 NCITES，这是 WG21 所属的更大的标准组织。这样他就可以继续参加标准会议了。没错。而 Muerte 认为这优先考虑保护 O'Dwyer，而不是更广泛社区的关切。这，哇，如果这是真的，那真的很令人不安。确实如此。
And it raises a really important ethical question. Should technical expertise excuse unethical behavior? And the answer is obviously no. Right. But it seems like some people in the C++ community aren't so sure. And Muerte doesn't stop there. She also points to cases where dissenting voices were silenced or pushed out of the community. Like who?
这提出了一个非常重要的伦理问题。技术专长是否可以成为不道德行为的借口？答案显然是否定的。没错。但看起来 C++ 社区中的一些人并不确定。而且 Muerte 并没有就此止步。她还指出了异议声音被压制或被挤出社区的案例。比如谁？
Well, she mentions Barbara Geller and Chandler Carruth. What happened to them? They were both reportedly removed from positions for challenging the status quo. So she's saying that the C++ community is intolerant of dissent. That's what she's arguing. Yeah. And she connects this to a broader problem of, well, let's just say negative behaviors within the community. Like what?
嗯，她提到了 Barbara Geller 和 Chandler Carruth。他们怎么了？据报道，他们两人都因为挑战现状而被免职。所以她是说 C++ 社区不能容忍异议。这就是她的论点。是的。她将此与更广泛的问题联系起来，嗯，让我们称之为社区内的负面行为。比如什么？
Well, she talks about how critics of safe C++ often resort to personal attacks and dismissive language instead of actually engaging with Baxter's ideas. Which is not how a healthy technical community should operate. Right. It should be about open discussion and debate, not about shutting down anyone who disagrees with you. And she points out this weird contradiction. The C++ community often rejects borrow checking because it supposedly creates dialects within the language. Right. But they seem to ignore all the existing variations in C++ usage that are already out there. Yeah. It's like they're saying our way is the only true way. Which is, well, it's hypocritical. And it stifles innovation.
嗯，她谈到了安全 C++ 的批评者经常诉诸人身攻击和轻蔑的语言，而不是真正参与 Baxter 的想法。这不是一个健康的技术社区应该运作的方式。没错。它应该关乎公开的讨论和辩论，而不是关闭任何不同意你的人。她指出了这种奇怪的矛盾。C++ 社区经常拒绝借用检查，因为据说它会在语言内部产生方言。没错。但他们似乎忽略了 C++ 使用中已经存在的所有现有变体。是的。这就像他们说“我们的方式是唯一正确的方式”。这，嗯，是虚伪的。而且它扼杀了创新。
Absolutely. And then she gets into Vinnie Falco, who's the head of the C++ Alliance. Oh, yeah. What about him? Well, he's been funding
绝对是。然后她谈到了 Vinnie Falco，他是 C++ 联盟（C++ Alliance）的负责人。哦，是的。他怎么了？嗯，他一直在资助
Sean Baxter's work on Safe C++, which sounds good on the surface, right? Yeah, it does. But Marte argues that it's not that simple. She says that Falco
Sean Baxter 在安全 C++ 方面的工作，这表面上听起来不错，对吧？是的，确实。但 Muerte 认为事情没那么简单。她说 Falco
has a history of control issues. And she cites his attempts to exert influence over the boost project as an example. So she's questioning his motives. Exactly. She's suggesting that he might be funding Baxter's work as a way to control safe C plus plus not out of any genuine desire to improve the language's safety. Hmm. That's interesting. And then there's the Boost logo controversy. Remember that? Vaguely. Remind me. Well, the proposed logo for Boost, which is a widely used C++ library, contains some imagery that some people found questionable. Oh, yeah. I remember that now.
有控制欲问题。她引用了他试图对 Boost 项目施加影响作为例子。所以她在质疑他的动机。没错。她暗示他资助 Baxter 的工作可能是一种控制安全 C++ 的方式，而不是出于任何真正想要提高语言安全性的愿望。嗯。这很有趣。还有 Boost 标志的争议。还记得吗？模模糊糊。提醒我一下。嗯，为 Boost（一个广泛使用的 C++ 库）提议的标志包含了一些人们认为有问题的意象。哦，是的，我现在想起来了。
And this raised concerns about Falco's judgment, especially given his association with John Kalb, who, as we discussed earlier, defended Arthur O'Dwyer. So it all ties back together. Exactly. And it paints a pretty troubling picture of the C++ alliance. Yeah, it does. So we've covered a lot of ground here, but there's still more to discuss. Muerte goes on to connect the C++ memory safety debate to the hype surrounding AI. And she even brings up the 1967 film Year 1999 AD, which is a fascinating look at how people used to envision the future.
这引发了对 Falco 判断力的担忧，特别是考虑到他与 John Kalb 的联系，正如我们之前讨论的那样，John Kalb 为 Arthur O'Dwyer 辩护过。所以这一切都联系在一起了。没错。这描绘了 C++ 联盟相当令人不安的画面。是的，确实。所以我们在这里涵盖了很多内容，但还有更多需要讨论。Muerte 继续将 C++ 内存安全辩论与围绕 AI 的炒作联系起来。她甚至提到了 1967 年的电影《公元 1999 年》（Year 1999 AD），这是一部迷人的电影，展示了人们过去如何设想未来。
So stay tuned for part two where we'll dive into all that. Looking forward to it. Me too. This is, well, this is quite the deep dive. It is. It really makes you think about the people behind the code and the power dynamics that shape the technology we use every day. And it's not just about criticizing the C++ community. Morate's blog post actually goes
所以请继续关注第二部分，我们将深入探讨所有这些内容。很期待。我也是。这，嗯，这是一次相当深入的探讨。确实。它真的让你思考代码背后的人，以及塑造我们每天使用的技术的权力动态。而且这不仅仅是关于批评 C++ 社区。Muerte 的博文实际上走得
deeper. She calls for a more inclusive, more ethical approach to how we design languages. And she brings up this concept of feminism, but not just about gender equality, you know? Right. Like I've heard this idea before that applying a feminist lens to tech can lead to better outcomes for everyone. Exactly. It's about thinking about the users, their experiences, promoting empathy, understanding and encouraging a collaborative approach when making decisions. Which, to be honest, a lot of popular languages already do, even if they don't call it feminist. Totally. Like look at languages like hair or zig. They're designed by individuals, not committees. And they really value user feedback and community involvement.
更深。她呼吁以一种更具包容性、更合乎道德的方式来设计语言。她提出了女性主义的概念，但不仅仅是关于性别平等，你知道的？没错。就像我以前听过这个想法，即对技术应用女性主义视角可以为每个人带来更好的结果。没错。这是关于考虑用户、他们的体验，促进同理心、理解，并在做决定时鼓励协作方法。说实话，许多流行的语言已经这样做了，即使它们不称之为女性主义。完全正确。就像看看像 Hare 或 Zig 这样的语言。它们是由个人设计的，而不是委员会。而且它们确实重视用户反馈和社区参与。
So they see the language creator as more of a steward, not a dictator. Exactly. And Morte brings up this example, Amy J. Koh's language called Wordplay, which is all about user centricity and experimentation. Okay. I haven't heard of that one. How does that work? Well, Koh encourages users to share their experiences and ideas. It's more collaborative than just submitting bug reports or suggestions, you know.
所以他们将语言创造者视为管家，而不是独裁者。没错。Muerte 举了这个例子，Amy J. Ko 的名为 Wordplay 的语言，它完全是关于以用户为中心和实验性的。好的。我没听说过那个。它是如何运作的？嗯，Ko 鼓励用户分享他们的经验和想法。这比仅仅提交错误报告或建议更具协作性，你知道的。
So it's more about building something together as a community. Yeah, it's about moving away from that traditional top-down model where a few people make all the decisions. I see. So back to C++, Moritze suggesting that maybe it's struggling because it hasn't embraced these ideas? Well, she acknowledges that it's tougher for bigger languages like C++ with its committee structure, but she still sees those, let's just call them problematic behaviors at play. Right. And just to be clear, we're not saying that everything masculine is bad. It's about recognizing those harmful behaviors that can pop up when traditional masculinity goes too far. Absolutely. It's about recognizing those patterns and trying to break free from them.
所以这更多是关于作为一个社区共同构建一些东西。是的，这是关于远离那种少数人做出所有决定的传统自上而下的模式。我明白了。所以回到 C++，Muerte 暗示它可能正在挣扎，因为它没有拥抱这些想法？嗯，她承认对于像 C++ 这样拥有委员会结构的大型语言来说，这更困难，但她仍然看到了那些，让我们称之为有问题行为的存在。没错。为了清楚起见，我们并不是说所有男性化的东西都是坏的。这是关于识别当传统男性气质走得太远时可能出现的那些有害行为。绝对是。这是关于识别这些模式并试图摆脱它们。
So what does that look like in the C++ community? Like what specific behaviors is she talking about? Well, she mentions this constant need to prove technical superiority, dismissing alternative viewpoints using aggressive or dismissive language. It's like winning the argument becomes more important than finding the best solution. That's a, yeah, that's a problem for sure. It creates this toxic environment where people are afraid to speak up or share new ideas. And it pushes away people who don't fit the stereotype of a C++ programmer, which limits innovation. For sure. So does she give any specific examples of this behavior? Yeah. She talks about John Lakos, a committee member who got caught recording conversations during a meeting because he didn't get his way on a proposal.
那么这在 C++ 社区中是什么样子的？她指的是什么具体行为？嗯，她提到了这种不断证明技术优越性的需求，使用攻击性或轻蔑的语言驳回替代观点。这就像赢得争论变得比找到最佳解决方案更重要。那是一个，是的，那肯定是个问题。它创造了一个有毒的环境，人们害怕发言或分享新想法。而且它排斥了那些不符合 C++ 程序员刻板印象的人，这限制了创新。当然。那么她有没有给出这种行为的具体例子？是的。她谈到了 John Lakos，一位委员会成员，他因为在提案上没有如愿，被抓到在会议期间录音。
Wow. Seriously. Yeah. And then there's Vivol, another committee member who apparently insulted other members and said things like, forget you and your proposal. That's just unprofessional and completely unhelpful. Right. It creates this hostile environment.
哇。真的吗？是的。然后是 Vivol，另一位委员会成员，他显然侮辱了其他成员，并说了诸如“去你的，还有你的提案”之类的话。这太不专业了，而且完全无济于事。没错。它创造了一个敌对的环境。
And then she shares her own experience with harassment on the C++ Slack. Oh no, what happened? So the C++ Slack is run by the C++ Alliance, and she was targeted by Glenn Fernandes, a committee contributor who apparently harassed her for hours. Oh wow, that's awful. What did she do? She reported it to Herb Sutter, but he initially threatened to ban her from the center. Seriously? That's just backwards.
然后她分享了她自己在 C++ Slack 上被骚扰的经历。哦，不，发生了什么？所以 C++ Slack 是由 C++ 联盟运营的，她被 Glenn Fernandes 盯上了，他是一位委员会贡献者，显然骚扰了她几个小时。哦，哇，那太糟糕了。她做了什么？她向 Herb Sutter 报告了这件事，但他最初威胁要禁止她进入中心。真的吗？那简直是倒退。
Yeah. And it was only after she showed him screenshots of the conversation that action was taken against Fernandez, who was told not to contact her again. That's worrying. It seems like there's this tendency to protect established members even when they're clearly in the wrong. her again? That's that's worrying. It seems like there's this tendency to protect established members even when they're clearly in the wrong. Right. It raises questions about how seriously they take these kinds of complaints. And speaking of the C++ Alliance, Murtay gets into Vinnie Falco's actions. You know, he's the head of the alliance. Yeah. And he's been funding Sean Baxter's work on safe C++. Right. He has, which on the surface seems like a good thing.
是的。直到她向他展示了对话截图后，才对 Fernandez 采取了行动，他被告知不得再联系她。这很令人担忧。似乎有一种保护既定成员的倾向，即使他们显然是错的。她？这很令人担忧。似乎有一种保护既定成员的倾向，即使他们显然是错的。没错。这引发了关于他们对这类投诉有多认真对待的问题。说到 C++ 联盟，Muerte 谈到了 Vinnie Falco 的行为。你知道，他是联盟的负责人。是的。他一直在资助 Sean Baxter 在安全 C++ 方面的工作。没错。他确实资助了，这表面上看起来是一件好事。
Yeah, supporting a project that could make C++ safer, great. But Muerte suggests it might not be that simple. She's concerned about Falco's history. She describes him as having control issues and brings up how he tried to influence the Boost project. So it's like, is he supporting safe C++ because he genuinely believes in it or because he wants to control it? Exactly. That's the question. And then there's the whole Boost logo controversy. Remember that? Oh, yeah. Vaguely refresh my memory.
是的，支持一个可以让 C++ 更安全的项目，太棒了。但 Muerte 暗示事情可能没那么简单。她担心 Falco 的过去。她形容他有控制欲问题，并提到了他如何试图影响 Boost 项目。所以就像，他支持安全 C++ 是因为他真心相信它，还是因为他想控制它？没错。这就是问题所在。还有 Boost 标志的争议。还记得吗？哦，是的。模模糊糊，帮我回忆一下。
The proposed logo for Boost, that C++ library, apparently had some, let's say, questionable imagery. Right. It raised questions about Falco's judgment, especially since he's associated with John Kalb, who defended Arthur O'Dwyer. It's like all these things start connecting and it doesn't look good for the C++ Alliance. No, not really. So what else does Morite get into? Well, she makes this interesting connection between the C++ memory safety debate and the whole AI hype. Okay.
为 Boost（那个 C++ 库）提议的标志显然有一些，怎么说呢，有问题的意象。没错。这引发了对 Falco 判断力的质疑，特别是考虑到他与 John Kalb 的联系，而 John Kalb 为 Arthur O'Dwyer 辩护过。就像所有这些事情都联系在一起了，这对 C++ 联盟来说看起来不太好。不，确实不太好。那么 Muerte 还谈到了什么？嗯，她将 C++ 内存安全辩论与整个 AI 炒作联系起来，这很有趣。好的。
I'm curious. How does she tie those together? She sees both as being driven by this desire for a silver bullet solution, you know, a quick fix that solves everything. Right, like a magic wand that makes all the problems disappear. Exactly. But both AI and these safety profiles are being presented as cure-alls, which is dangerous because it sets up unrealistic expectations. And when those expectations aren't met, people get disillusioned and disappointed. And it distracts from the real work that needs to be done, which is addressing these complex issues in a thoughtful and nuanced way.
我很好奇。她是如何将它们联系在一起的？她认为两者都是由这种对“银弹”解决方案的渴望所驱动的，你知道的，一种解决一切问题的快速修复方法。没错，就像一根让所有问题消失的魔杖。没错。但 AI 和这些安全配置文件都被呈现为万灵药，这很危险，因为它设定了不切实际的期望。当这些期望没有得到满足时，人们就会感到幻灭和失望。而且它分散了人们对真正需要完成的工作的注意力，即以一种深思熟虑和细致入微的方式解决这些复杂问题。
So it's not just about finding a technical solution. It's about changing the culture, the mindset. Exactly. And she specifically calls out Andrew Tomazos, who submitted a paper to the C++ committee that was actually generated by ChatGPT. Oh, wow. Seriously? Yeah. She sees it as a sign that some people are putting too much faith in AI. Like it can solve all our problems. Which is a bit naive, don't you think? It is. It's like we need to be careful not to let our enthusiasm for technology blind us to its limitations. Okay. so AI hype silver bullets. What else? Well,
所以这不仅仅是关于找到技术解决方案。这是关于改变文化、心态。没错。她特别点名了 Andrew Tomazos，他向 C++ 委员会提交了一篇实际上由 ChatGPT 生成的论文。哦，哇。真的吗？是的。她认为这是一个迹象，表明有些人对 AI 寄予了太多的信任。就像它可以解决我们所有的问题一样。这有点天真，你不觉得吗？确实。就像我们需要小心，不要让对技术的热情蒙蔽了我们对它局限性的认识。好的。所以 AI 炒作、银弹。还有什么？嗯，
Morette takes us back in time to 1967 with this film called Year 1999 AD. What's that about? It's basically this super optimistic vision of the future full of amazing technology and societal progress. Like a utopia. Basically, yeah. And she compares the promises made in that film to the state of the world today and the C++ community. Okay, I'm seeing the contrast already. We're not exactly living in the utopia, are we? Nope, not quite. And she argues that there's this disconnect between that old vision of the future and the reality we're facing now. Climate change, inequality, technological stagnation.
Muerte 把我们带回了 1967 年，那部名为《公元 1999 年》的电影。那是关于什么的？它基本上是对未来的一种超级乐观的愿景，充满了惊人的技术和社会进步。就像乌托邦。基本上是这样。她将那部电影中做出的承诺与当今世界和 C++ 社区的状态进行了比较。好的，我已经看到了对比。我们并没有真正生活在乌托邦里，对吧？没有，并不完全是。她认为，对未来的那种旧愿景与我们现在面临的现实之间存在脱节。气候变化、不平等、技术停滞。
Yeah. It's not pretty. Not really. And she ties this back to the C++ memory safety debate. She says this push for a quick fix like safety profiles comes from that same yearning for a simple solution. Like we just want to go back to that naive optimism of the past. Exactly. But she reminds us that that's not possible. We have to deal with the complexities of the present. So how do we move forward?
是的。这并不美好。确实不美好。她将此与 C++ 内存安全辩论联系起来。她说这种对像安全配置文件这样的快速修复的推动，源于对简单解决方案的同样渴望。就像我们只是想回到过去那种天真的乐观主义。没错。但她提醒我们，那是不可能的。我们必须处理现在的复杂性。那么我们如何前进？
Well, she brings back the Dark Souls analogy. Remember that? Oh, yeah. C++ is a video game. Interesting. Yeah. It's about these cycles of destruction and renewal, the struggle between clinging to the past and embracing change. And she compares Bjarni Straustrup to Gwyn, the Lord of Cinder, who sacrifices himself to prolong the Age of Fire, even though it's harmful in the long run. Right. It's like he's so focused on preserving his legacy that he's preventing C++ from adapting and evolving.
嗯，她带回了《黑暗之魂》（Dark Souls）的类比。还记得吗？哦，是的。C++ 是一款电子游戏。有趣。是的。它是关于毁灭与重生的循环，关于坚持过去与拥抱变革之间的斗争。她将 Bjarne Stroustrup 比作薪王葛温（Gwyn, the Lord of Cinder），他牺牲自己来延长火之时代，尽管从长远来看这是有害的。没错。就像他太专注于保护自己的遗产，以至于阻碍了 C++ 的适应和演进。
So what's the alternative? Well, Morte says we have a choice. We can keep clinging to the past, which might lead to the decline of C++, or we can choose a different path. A path that embraces the unknown and allows the language to grow in new ways. Exactly. It's a powerful message. It's about taking responsibility for the future of C++ and recognizing that we have the power to shape it. It's inspiring in a way. Yeah.
那么有什么替代方案？嗯，Muerte 说我们有一个选择。我们可以继续坚持过去，这可能会导致 C++ 的衰落，或者我们可以选择一条不同的道路。一条拥抱未知并允许语言以新方式成长的道路。没错。这是一个强有力的信息。这是关于为 C++ 的未来承担责任，并认识到我们有能力塑造它。在某种程度上很鼓舞人心。是的。
But also kind of daunting. It's a lot to think about. It is. But it's important. We need to have these conversations to challenge the status quo and to work towards a better future for C++ and for technology in general. I agree. So where do we go from here? What's next in Muerte's blog post? But Muerte doesn't stop there. She brings up Justine Tunney, you know, the programmer who created the Cosmopolitan C library. Oh yeah, I know her work. What about her? Well, Muerte speculates that the name Cosmopolitan itself might actually be a
但也让人望而生畏。有很多东西需要思考。确实。但这很重要。我们需要进行这些对话来挑战现状，并为 C++ 和整个技术的未来努力。我同意。那么我们从这里去向何方？Muerte 的博文接下来是什么？但 Muerte 并没有就此止步。她提到了 Justine Tunney，你知道的，那个创建了 Cosmopolitan C 库的程序员。哦，是的，我知道她的工作。她怎么了？嗯，Muerte 推测“Cosmopolitan”这个名字本身可能实际上是
reference to a term that well has some problematic historical baggage huh that's interesting I hadn't thought about that but I can see how that could be a concern yeah and she also points to some of Tunney's past tweets some of which have apparently been deleted or removed from archives like she mentions one where Tunney praises AI for quote elevating the universe to a higher state of complexity. Okay. And what's wrong with that? When Werte suggests that it might align with certain ideologies that, let's just say, not everyone is comfortable with.
一个术语的引用，嗯，带有一些有问题的历史包袱。哈，这很有趣，我没想过那个，但我能看出那可能是一个担忧。是的，她还指出了 Tunney 的一些过去推文，其中一些显然已经被删除或从存档中移除了，就像她提到的一条，Tunney 称赞 AI “将宇宙提升到更高的复杂性状态”。好的。那有什么问题吗？Muerte 暗示它可能与某些意识形态一致，嗯，让我们说，并不是每个人都感到舒服。
I see. So it's more about the potential implications of that statement. Right. And it raises questions about how we interpret and contextualize online statements, especially ones that might have been made years ago. Yeah. It's tricky because people's views can change over time, and it's not always fair to judge someone based on something they said in the past. True. But it's also important to acknowledge that words have power and that even seemingly harmless statements can carry unintended meanings. Absolutely. Context is everything. And that brings us back to the C++ community. Huerte argues that this resistance to change this embrace of, well, let's just say certain negative behaviors, it all stems from a fear of losing control. A fear of the unknown. Exactly. And she suggests that this fear is what's preventing C++ from evolving to meet the
我明白了。所以这更多是关于该声明的潜在含义。没错。这引发了关于我们如何解释和语境化在线声明的问题，特别是那些可能是几年前做出的声明。是的。这很棘手，因为人们的观点会随着时间的推移而改变，根据某人过去说的话来评判他们并不总是公平的。确实。但同样重要的是要承认言语具有力量，即使是看似无害的声明也可能带有意想不到的含义。绝对是。语境就是一切。这把我们带回了 C++ 社区。Muerte 认为这种对变革的抵制，这种对，嗯，让我们说，某些负面行为的拥抱，都源于对失去控制的恐惧。对未知的恐惧。没错。她暗示这种恐惧正是阻碍 C++ 演进以满足
challenges of today's world. So it's like they're clinging to the past, even if it means holding the language back. Yeah, like Gwen in Dark Souls, sacrificing everything to maintain the status quo. Right. But as we know, that never ends well. Nope. It just leads to more suffering. And that's where Muerte leaves us with this dark choice. Cling to the past or embrace the uncertain future.
当今世界挑战的原因。所以就像他们坚持过去，即使这意味着阻碍语言的发展。是的，就像《黑暗之魂》中的葛温，牺牲一切来维持现状。没错。但正如我们所知，那从来没有好下场。不。它只会导致更多的痛苦。这就是 Muerte 留给我们的黑暗选择。坚持过去，还是拥抱不确定的未来。
It's a powerful question. And it's not just relevant to C++. It applies to all of us in tech and beyond. It does. It's about recognizing that change is inevitable and that we can either resist it or we can try to shape it. And that shaping, that's where the real work lies. It's about being intentional, about considering the ethical implications of our choices and about building a future that benefits everyone, not just a select few. And that's a future worth fighting for. So, listener, what are your takeaways from all of this?
这是一个强有力的问题。而且它不仅与 C++ 相关。它适用于我们所有从事技术及其他领域的人。确实。这是关于认识到变革是不可避免的，我们可以抵制它，也可以尝试塑造它。而那种塑造，才是真正的工作所在。这是关于有意识，关于考虑我们选择的伦理影响，以及关于构建一个造福所有人，而不仅仅是少数人的未来。那是一个值得为之奋斗的未来。所以，听众朋友们，你们从这一切中得到了什么？
Did this deep dive change how you view C++ or the tech industry in general? I know it's given me a lot to think about, and I hope it's done the same for you. We've covered a lot of ground from memory safety and borrow checking to feminist design principles of the role of AI. But this is just the beginning of the conversation. There is always more to explore, more perspectives to consider and more work to be done. So keep questioning, keep learning and keep pushing for a better future. Well said. And on that note, thanks for joining us on this deep dive listener. Until next time, keep exploring.
这次深入探讨是否改变了你对 C++ 或整个科技行业的看法？我知道它让我思考了很多，我希望它对你也一样。我们涵盖了很多内容，从内存安全和借用检查到女性主义设计原则和 AI 的作用。但这只是对话的开始。总有更多的东西需要探索，更多的视角需要考虑，更多的工作需要完成。所以保持质疑，保持学习，并继续推动一个更美好的未来。说得好。在此，感谢听众朋友们加入我们的深入探讨。下次见，继续探索。
All right, let's dive in. Today, we're looking at this really interesting discussion that's been happening over on Reddit. It all started with a blog post called On Safe C++. And, well, it's safe to say it stirred up some strong feelings in the C++ community. Yeah, no kidding. It's a pretty provocative piece. Over 400 comments now, and people are not holding back. So we've got this blog post, a mountain of comments, lots to unpack. We're going to try and make sense of it all for you, break down the arguments, look at different perspectives, and hopefully shed some light on what it all means for the future of C++ play.
好的，让我们深入探讨一下。今天，我们来看看 Reddit 上正在进行的这场非常有趣的讨论。这一切始于一篇名为《论安全 C++》的博文。嗯，可以肯定地说，它在 C++ 社区中引发了强烈的情绪。没错，确实如此。这是一篇相当挑衅的文章。现在已经有超过 400 条评论了，人们毫不掩饰自己的观点。所以我们有这篇博文，堆积如山的评论，有很多需要拆解的内容。我们将尝试为你理清这一切，分解论点，审视不同的视角，并希望阐明这一切对 C++ 的未来意味着什么。
Yeah, we'll give it our best shot. Okay. So first things first, the blog post itself, it's written by someone who goes by Simon Toro. They're pretty deep in the C++ world, but it's clear they're not happy with the direction things are heading. Right. Simon Toro's main point is that, well, they argue that the C++ community just isn't willing to take safety seriously enough. And they're very critical of the standards committee and some of the big names in C++ laros. One of the things they really go after is safety profiles, right? This is something that folks like Herb Sutter and even Darnie Strauster are pushing for. Can you give us a quick, quick explainer on what these safety profiles actually are and why they're causing such a fuss? Sure. So in a nutshell, safety profiles are a way of defining different levels of, you know, safety guarantees for C++ code. The idea is that you could choose a profile that kind of matches the specific needs of your project, whether you're prioritizing, I don't know, performance or you need really tight security.
是的，我们会尽力而为。好的。首先，博文本身是由一个叫 Simon Toro 的人写的。他们对 C++ 世界了解很深，但很明显他们对事情的发展方向不满意。没错。Simon Toro 的主要观点是，嗯，他们认为 C++ 社区根本不愿意足够认真地对待安全性。他们对标准委员会和 C++ 领域的一些大人物非常挑剔。他们真正攻击的事情之一是安全配置文件，对吧？这是像 Herb Sutter 甚至 Bjarne Stroustrup 这样的人正在推动的事情。你能给我们快速解释一下这些安全配置文件到底是什么，以及为什么它们引起了这么大的骚动吗？当然。简而言之，安全配置文件是一种为 C++ 代码定义不同级别的，你知道的，安全保证的方法。这个想法是，你可以选择一个符合你项目特定需求的配置文件，无论你是优先考虑，我不知道，性能，还是你需要非常严格的安全性。
But Simon Schultz's argument is that it's just not enough. So are they saying the idea itself is bad or just that it's not going far enough? I think it's more the latter. They see it as kind of a Band-Aid solution. Like it won't actually address the underlying issues with C++ itself. Interesting. So they're saying if you really want safety,
但 Simon Toro 的论点是，这还不够。所以他们是说这个想法本身很糟糕，还是说它做得不够？我认为更多是后者。他们将其视为一种“创可贴”式的解决方案。就像它实际上不会解决 C++ 本身潜在的问题一样。有趣。所以他们是说如果你真的想要安全，
you need to make more fundamental changes. Exactly. Simon Dennis Lee thinks C++ needs to learn from languages like Rust, which were built with safety in mind right from the start. And this is where things start to get really, really heated. Because Simon, though, isn't just critiquing the technical side of things. They're also implying that, well, that some of the people pushing safety profiles might have ulterior motives.
你需要做出更根本的改变。没错。Simon Toro 认为 C++ 需要向 Rust 这样的语言学习，这些语言从一开始就是考虑到安全性而构建的。这就是事情开始变得非常、非常激烈的地方。因为 Simon Toro 不仅仅是在批评技术方面。他们还暗示，嗯，一些推动安全配置文件的人可能有不可告人的动机。
Yeah, they actually suggest that folks like Sutter and Strauss-Stripp might be promoting safety profiles because it, well, because it benefits them somehow. Maybe even to stifle alternative solutions that might be, you know, more effective in the long run. Wow. I mean, that's a pretty serious accusation to throw around. No wonder the Reddit thread blew up. You've got people who wholeheartedly agree with Simon Hopfo. They're saying C++ needs to be more open to change, you know, and that safety profiles aren't the magic bullet that some people are making them out to be. But then, of course, you've got the other side, those who are fiercely defensive of C++ and see this whole thing as an attack on the language itself. For sure. Some people are
是的，他们实际上暗示像 Sutter 和 Stroustrup 这样的人可能正在推广安全配置文件，因为，嗯，因为它在某种程度上对他们有利。甚至可能是为了扼杀从长远来看可能，你知道的，更有效的替代解决方案。哇。我的意思是，这是一个相当严重的指控。难怪 Reddit 帖子会爆炸。有些人全心全意地同意 Simon Toro。他们说 C++ 需要对变革更加开放，你知道的，而且安全配置文件并不是某些人所说的那种灵丹妙药。但当然，你也有另一方，那些激烈捍卫 C++ 并将整件事视为对语言本身的攻击的人。当然。有些人
accusing Simo of being disrespectful, unprofessional even, you know, especially when it comes to how they talk about Herb Sutter and Bjorni Stroustrup. Oh, right. The rust derangement syndrome thing. You see that pop up anytime someone criticizes C++ and then praises rust in the same breath. Oh, yeah. It's a classic. Like you can't possibly like both. Well, it's not that simple, is it? I mean, there's room for both languages. They both have their strengths and weaknesses. And this is about more than just C++ versus Rust anyway. It's about the culture of the C++ community, the power dynamics within the standards committee, you know, the whole ethical dimension of it all.
指责 Simon Toro 不尊重人，甚至不专业，你知道的，特别是在他们谈论 Herb Sutter 和 Bjarne Stroustrup 的方式上。哦，对了。那个“Rust 错乱综合征”的事。每当有人批评 C++ 并在同一时间赞美 Rust 时，你就会看到这种说法冒出来。哦，是的。这是经典桥段。就好像你不可能同时喜欢这两者一样。嗯，事情没那么简单，对吧？我的意思是，这两种语言都有生存空间。它们各有优缺点。而且这不仅仅是 C++ 与 Rust 的对立。这关乎 C++ 社区的文化、标准委员会内部的权力动态，你知道的，还有这一切背后的整个伦理维度。
You're absolutely right. And that's what makes this whole discussion so fascinating. It's a window into the human side of software development. All the drama and politics and, you know, everything that goes on behind the scenes. And Simon Doe doesn't shy away from naming names and pointing to specific incidents that they think illustrate these problems. Yeah, like the story about Yarnr Strauss storming out of a committee meeting because he didn't get his way. So Maranduo uses this to paint a picture of a committee that's resistant to change, you know, dominated by a few powerful figures. And then there's the whole
你说得完全正确。这就是让整个讨论如此迷人的原因。它是了解软件开发人性化的一扇窗。所有的戏剧性、政治，以及，你知道的，幕后发生的一切。而 Simon Toro 毫不避讳地点名并指出他们认为说明这些问题的具体事件。是的，比如关于 Bjarne Stroustrup 因为没能如愿而冲出委员会会议的故事。所以 Simon Toro 用这个来描绘一个抵制变革、你知道的，由少数有权势的人物主导的委员会。还有整个
controversy surrounding Arthur O'Dwyer, a C++ speaker and committee member who, well, he's a convicted sex offender. Right. And Simon Carono argues that allowing O'Dwyer to remain active in the community sends a really dangerous message. They say it raises serious questions about the committee's priorities. They even claim that there have been attempts to silence discussion about O'Dwyer's conviction. Wow, that's a lot to unpack. It adds another layer of complexity to this whole debate. It definitely does. And for Simon Carono, it's just one more piece of evidence that the C++ community isn't really serious about safety and reform. So what we have here is a very strongly worded blog post that's clearly struck a nerve.
围绕 Arthur O'Dwyer 的争议，他是一位 C++ 演讲者和委员会成员，嗯，他是一名被定罪的性犯罪者。没错。而 Simon Toro 认为允许 O'Dwyer 继续在社区中活跃会发出一个非常危险的信号。他们说这引发了关于委员会优先事项的严重问题。他们甚至声称有人试图压制关于 O'Dwyer 定罪的讨论。哇，这有很多需要拆解的内容。它为整个辩论增加了一层复杂性。确实如此。对于 Simon Toro 来说，这只是 C++ 社区并不真正认真对待安全和改革的又一个证据。所以我们这里有一篇措辞非常强烈的博文，显然触动了神经。
And the Reddit discussion is like a microcosm of all the tension and anxiety surrounding the future of C++. You've got those who believe that C++ can adapt and evolve to meet these new demands for safety and security. And then you have others who think, you know, that C++ can adapt and evolve to meet these new demands for safety and security. And then you have others who think, you know, that C++ is fundamentally flawed, that its legacy is holding it back and the community is just too resistant to change. It's a really fascinating debate and one we're going to keep digging into. Now, let's jump into the Reddit thread itself and see what people are saying. All right. So let's take a look at these reactions. See what people are saying in the comments.
而 Reddit 的讨论就像是围绕 C++ 未来所有紧张和焦虑的缩影。你有那些相信 C++ 可以适应和演进以满足这些对安全和保障的新需求的人。然后你有其他人认为，你知道的，C++ 从根本上是有缺陷的，它的遗产正在阻碍它，而社区对变革太抵制了。这是一个非常迷人的辩论，我们将继续深入探讨。现在，让我们跳进 Reddit 帖子本身，看看人们在说什么。好的。那么让我们来看看这些反应。看看人们在评论中说了什么。
Because let's be real. A blog post like that going to get people talking. Oh, yeah. It's like a war zone in there. People arguing about everything, whether Simono is right, yeah, Simon's spot on. They agree that the committee is resistant to change and that safety profiles just aren't enough. Right. And you can really feel the frustration from those folks. Like they're tired of waiting for the language to catch up to the, you know, the demands of modern software development. Yeah. It's almost like they feel like they're not being heard, you know. But it's not all agreement, right? There's a whole bunch of people who, even if they share some of the same concerns, they really don't like the tone, the way Simon went about saying all this. Yeah, there's a lot of that, what do they call it, tone policing. People saying Simon, although it was too harsh, too disrespectful, especially towards, you know, legends like
因为说实话，那样的博客文章肯定会引发讨论。哦，是的，那里简直就像个战场。人们在争论一切，比如Simono说得对不对，是的，Simon说得很到位。他们一致认为委员会拒绝改变，仅仅依靠安全配置文件是不够的。没错。你真的能感受到那些人的沮丧。就像他们厌倦了等待语言的发展跟上现代软件开发的各种需求。是的，感觉就像他们觉得自己的声音没有被听到。但并非所有人都同意，对吧？还有一大群人，即使他们有同样的担忧，他们也非常不喜欢这种语气，不喜欢Simon表达这一切的方式。是的，有很多所谓的“语气警察”。人们说Simon虽然说得有道理，但太严厉、太不尊重人了，尤其是对像Sutter和Stroustrup这样的传奇人物。
Sutter and Straustrup. Well, yeah, I disrespectful, especially towards legends like Sutter and Strausdrup. Well, yeah, I mean, you can't just go around dissing C++ royalty like that and expect everyone to be cool with it. It's interesting, though, because some of the most thoughtful comments are coming from people who are actually on the C++ committee. Like Neil Douglas, he's been pretty vocal about the committee's, let's say, shortcomings. Right. And Douglas actually kind of backs up some of what I was saying. He talks about how the committee can get stuck in this, you know, this negative spiral, shooting down new ideas instead of, you know, actually trying to build something better.
Sutter和Stroustrup。嗯，是的，我不尊重人，尤其是对像Sutter和Stroustrup这样的传奇人物。嗯，是的，我的意思是，你不能到处诋毁C++界的泰斗，还指望每个人都觉得没问题。不过这很有趣，因为一些最有深度的评论来自那些实际上在C++委员会工作的人。比如Neil Douglas，他一直直言不讳地批评委员会的所谓“缺点”。没错。Douglas实际上在某种程度上支持了我刚才所说的一些观点。他谈到委员会是如何陷入这种负面循环的，总是否定新想法，而不是真正尝试去构建更好的东西。
Right. And that lack of engagement is something that Gabourey Sidibe brought up, too. They ended up leaving the committee because it was just, I don't know, too frustrating to deal with. And Sidibe's point is that the committee just isn't equipped to handle the really big, complex stuff. They're too focused on these tiny incremental changes. They're not willing to tackle the really fundamental problems that Simon Smith is talking about. So even within the committee itself, you've got people saying, hey, something's not right here. I mean, that kind of lends some credibility to Simon Sko's argument, doesn't it? Oh, for sure. It suggests it's not just, you know, one person complaining. There might be some real systemic issues here. And then, of course, you've got the O'Dwyer situation, which just throws everything into chaos. Yeah, it's a tough one. It's definitely causing a lot of pain and division
没错。Gabourey Sidibe也提到了这种缺乏参与感的问题。他们最终离开了委员会，因为处理这些事情太令人沮丧了。Sidibe的观点是，委员会根本没有能力处理那些真正重大、复杂的问题。他们太专注于这些微小的增量变化，而不愿意解决Simon Smith所谈论的那些真正根本性的问题。所以即使在委员会内部，也有人说，嘿，这里有些不对劲。我的意思是，这在某种程度上增加了Simon Sko论点的可信度，不是吗？哦，当然。这表明这不仅仅是一个人在抱怨。这里可能存在一些真正的系统性问题。然后，当然，还有O'Dwyer的情况，这让一切都陷入了混乱。是的，这是一个棘手的问题。它确实在C++社区中造成了很大的痛苦和分裂。
in the C++ community. You've got people trying to downplay it saying, you know, let's move on. It's in the past. And then others saying, absolutely not. This makes it even worse. It makes you wonder who the committee is actually serving, you know? Are they really prioritizing the safety and well-being of the entire C++ community? It's a good reminder that we can't just have these technical discussions in a vacuum. The ethical side of things matters just as much. A hundred percent. And it all comes back to this question of what does safe C++ even mean? Is it even possible? Because Simonow is saying it's not enough to just add on these extra features like safety profiles. They want to see a real change in the way people think about C++A, how they use it. Right. And they keep bringing up Rust as the example to follow.
在C++社区中。有些人试图淡化这件事，说，你知道，让我们继续前进吧，这已经是过去式了。而另一些人则说，绝对不行，这让情况变得更糟了。这让你不禁想问，委员会到底是在为谁服务？他们真的在优先考虑整个C++社区的安全和福祉吗？这是一个很好的提醒，我们不能在真空中进行这些技术讨论。伦理方面的问题同样重要。百分之百。这一切又回到了“什么是安全的C++”这个问题上。这真的可能吗？因为Simonow说，仅仅增加像安全配置文件这样的额外功能是不够的。他们希望看到人们对C++的思考方式以及使用方式发生真正的改变。没错。而且他们一直把Rust作为效仿的榜样。
They specifically talk about Rust's borrow checker. Okay. You might need to explain that one for me. What is this borrow checker thing and why does Simon Everwood think it's so important? Think of it like imagine you're lending someone a book, right? You wouldn't want them to accidentally tear out pages or spill coffee on it. Right. Well, hopefully not. Well, the borrow checker in Rust is kind of like a really, really strict librarian. It's got all these rules about how you can access data in your
他们特别谈到了Rust的借用检查器。好吧，你可能需要为我解释一下。这个借用检查器是什么东西，为什么Simon Everwood认为它如此重要？把它想象成你借给别人一本书，对吧？你肯定不希望他们不小心撕掉书页或把咖啡洒在上面。没错。嗯，希望不会。好吧，Rust中的借用检查器就像一个非常、非常严格的图书管理员。它有一套关于你如何访问代码中数据的规则，
code, you know, to prevent those kinds of mistakes that can lead to memory errors and security holes. So it's kind of like a built-in safety net. Exactly. And Simon Ferraio's argument is that C++ needs something like that if it wants to be truly safe. Of course, not everyone agrees. Yeah. I mean, I can see how trying to add something like that to C++ could be a nightmare. Of course, not everyone agrees. They say C++ is all about flexibility, you know, giving the programmer the power to do what they need to do and giving that up in the name of safety. Well, they see that as a huge mistake. So is this like an unresolvable conflict then? Can you really have safety and flexibility at the same time?
你知道，为了防止那些可能导致内存错误和安全漏洞的错误。所以它就像一个内置的安全网。完全正确。Simon Ferraio的论点是，如果C++想要真正安全，就需要类似的东西。当然，并不是每个人都同意。是的，我的意思是，我能看出试图在C++中加入这样的东西可能是一场噩梦。当然，并不是每个人都同意。他们说C++的核心就是灵活性，你知道，赋予程序员做他们需要做的事情的权力，而为了安全放弃这一点，嗯，他们认为这是一个巨大的错误。那么，这是一个无法解决的冲突吗？你真的能同时拥有安全性和灵活性吗？
That's the million dollar question, right? And I don't think there's a simple yes or no answer. Maybe there's a middle ground somewhere, a way to make C++ safer without completely overhauling it and alienating, you know, all of the people who already use it. So we're seeing this tension play out in the Reddit discussion, right? You've got the purists who are like, C++ is perfect as it is. Don't touch it. And then you've got those who are like, wake up, people. The world's changing. Software needs to change with it, even if it means making some tough choices. And all of this is happening while the O'Dwyer thing is just hanging over everything. Yeah. Yeah. It's a messy situation. No easy answers there. But I think it
这就是那个价值百万美元的问题，对吧？我不认为有一个简单的“是”或“否”的答案。也许中间有某种折中方案，一种在不彻底重构C++并疏远所有现有用户的情况下使其更安全的方法。所以我们正在Reddit的讨论中看到这种张力，对吧？你有那些纯粹主义者，他们认为C++现在就很完美，别动它。然后你有那些说“醒醒吧，人们，世界在变，软件也需要随之改变，即使这意味着要做出一些艰难的选择”。而所有这一切发生的同时，O'Dwyer事件就像阴影一样笼罩着一切。是的，是的。这是一个混乱的局面，没有简单的答案。但我认为它
just highlights the point that, you know, we can't separate the technical stuff from the ethical stuff. It's all connected. It reminds us that software is built by people and the choices we make. Well, they have real world consequences. It feels us that software is built by people and the choices we make. Well, they have real world consequences. It feels like we've just scratched the surface here and we've already gone through so much. It's a big topic, isn't it? All these different layers, technical stuff, the social dynamics, the ethical questions. It's all tangled up together.
只是突出了这一点，你知道，我们不能把技术问题和伦理问题分开。它们是相互关联的。它提醒我们，软件是由人构建的，我们所做的选择，嗯，它们有现实世界的影响。感觉我们只是触及了表面，就已经讨论了这么多。这是一个很大的话题，不是吗？所有这些不同的层面，技术问题、社会动态、伦理问题。它们全都纠缠在一起。
For sure. And, you know, I bet some people listening are thinking, well, this is all very interesting. But I don't write C++ Oaks, so what's it to me? But I think that misses the bigger picture. I agree. This is way bigger than just one language. It's about the future of software, period. And let's face it, software runs the world now. Pretty much, yeah. Our phones, our banks, the power grid, hospitals, you name it. It's all software. And that means the stakes are
当然。而且，你知道，我敢打赌有些听众会想，嗯，这很有趣，但我又不写C++代码，这跟我有什么关系？但我认为这忽略了更大的图景。我同意。这远不止是一种语言的问题。这是关于软件的未来，句号。让我们面对现实吧，软件现在运行着整个世界。差不多是这样，是的。我们的手机、银行、电网、医院，随便你说什么。全都是软件。这意味着风险
incredibly high. If one little piece of code has a flaw, the consequences can be catastrophic. And that's why this whole safe C++ debate is so important. I mean, so much critical software is written in C++O. So if C++ isn't safe, those systems aren't safe either. Right. And we've seen it happen time and again. Data breaches, financial crashes, infrastructure failures. A lot of it goes back to software vulnerabilities. So this isn't just some abstract academic argument. It's about the security and reliability of the systems that we depend on every single day.
高得惊人。如果一小段代码有缺陷，后果可能是灾难性的。这就是为什么整个“安全C++”的辩论如此重要。我的意思是，这么多关键软件都是用C++编写的。所以如果C++不安全，那些系统也不安全。没错。我们已经一次又一次地看到了这种情况发生。数据泄露、金融崩溃、基础设施故障。很多都归结为软件漏洞。所以这不仅仅是一些抽象的学术争论。这是关于我们每天依赖的系统的安全性和可靠性。
Exactly. This is something everyone should care about, not just programmers. We all rely on this stuff, whether we realize it or not. So is this it then? Is C++ doomed? Are we just stuck with these vulnerabilities as the cost of doing business? Well, that's the big question. And like we've been saying, there's no easy answer. Simon Sio and those who agree with them, they seem to be saying C++ is just too far gone, too complex, too resistant to change. They say we should just move on to other languages like Rust. Yeah, the start fresh approach. But then you've got people who are convinced that C++ can evolve. They point to things like the safety profiles as proof that the community is taking this seriously. They argue that C++ is strength is its power. It gives you so
没错。这是每个人都应该关心的事情，不仅仅是程序员。我们都依赖这些东西，无论我们是否意识到。所以这就是结局了吗？C++注定要失败吗？我们是否只能忍受这些漏洞作为经营的代价？嗯，这就是大问题。正如我们一直所说的，没有简单的答案。Simon Sio和那些同意他们观点的人，似乎在说C++已经无可救药了，太复杂，太抗拒改变。他们说我们应该转向Rust等其他语言。是的，那种“从头开始”的方法。但也有人坚信C++可以进化。他们指出安全配置文件等事物作为证明，说明社区正在认真对待这个问题。他们认为C++的优势在于它的强大。它赋予开发者
much control as a developer. And trading that for safety, well, in their view, that's a huge loss. It's tough. I get both sides. Part of me wants to see the progress, you know? Move to newer tools, languages that are built for the problems we face today. Right.
如此多的控制权。而为了安全而放弃这些，嗯，在他们看来，这是一个巨大的损失。这很难。我理解双方。我的一部分人想看到进步，你知道？转向更新的工具、为我们今天面临的问题而构建的语言。没错。
But then there's this incredible amount of knowledge and experience around C++ wire. It feels wrong to just throw all that away. Yeah, there's a practical considerations to the cost of migrating all that code, training people on new languages. It's a huge undertaking. It's a mess, but at least we're talking about it. The fact that people are challenging the status quo, pushing for something better, that has to be a good thing. Absolutely. It means we're becoming more aware of the risks, more serious about building software that's not just functional, but safe and secure.
但C++周围有如此惊人的知识和经验积累。仅仅把这一切扔掉感觉是不对的。是的，迁移所有这些代码、培训人们使用新语言的成本等实际考虑因素。这是一项巨大的工程。这很混乱，但至少我们在讨论它。人们挑战现状、推动更好的东西，这一定是一件好事。绝对是。这意味着我们越来越意识到风险，越来越认真地构建不仅功能强大，而且安全可靠的软件。
And I think that's the key takeaway for me. It's a call to action for everyone, not just developers. Think about the software you use. Demand better. Yeah. Push for higher standards because the future of software, it's not set in stone. It's something we all have a hand in creating through the choices we make, the tools we use. So that's something to think about. What kind of future do we want? One where software is a source of safety and stability or one where it's constantly putting us at risk? The choice is ours.
我认为这是我得到的主要收获。这对每个人来说都是一个行动号召，不仅仅是开发者。思考一下你使用的软件。要求更好的标准。是的，推动更高的标准，因为软件的未来不是一成不变的。这是我们所有人通过我们所做的选择、我们使用的工具共同创造的东西。所以这值得思考。我们想要什么样的未来？一个软件是安全和稳定源泉的未来，还是一个它不断让我们处于风险之中的未来？选择权在我们手中。
And that's about all the time we have for today. So until next time, stay curious and keep exploring. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们今天节目的全部时间了。所以下次见之前，保持好奇心，继续探索。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。